thank you all for coming this is a very
exciting day we have ahead of us and I'm
just starting off the day with some
introductory remarks followed by some
remarks by Mark Pagani and so first I
just wanted to say thank you all for
coming we're really excited about this
we have a really nice group of people
here both great eminent climate
scientists and I'm an economist's to
talk to us about the conversation about
climate science and economics and I
wanted to start out by thanking yci
thanking a yell climb and energy
institute for providing the funding and
the motivation and the effort no man
power behind this to make it all happy
and co-sponsorship by scrim you can look
at world wide web scrim hub com but
they're helping out as well and you can
speak to I guess Chris forest and class
Keller if you are interested learning
more about that so just wanted to start
that out and let me give some context
this is going to be an overview no
surprise to anyone here I'm sure so we
have the fifth assessment report the
Working Group one physical science basis
is already out and so this is a really
time this is a really timely meeting
there's a lot of discussion about this
going on now it was released an undated
form on September 30th 2013 I've spent
many hours already pouring through it
it's not the easiest read I will say the
full report will be published by January
to 4 2014 but on top of that we have the
conference of parties so there's lots
going on in the policy world as well so
we have a real action in the science
world and real action in the policy
world so with cop19 and more saw paris
going on who knows if it's actually
going to achieving anything but there's
a lot of conversation about climate
change going on scheduled to end
actually tomorrow so given that just
want to talk briefly about what what
we're talking about this is really a
conversation about uncertainty today and
there are many uncertainties now this is
from the IPCC ar5 and it's fun as an
economist I get to put up a physical
science slide but what we see is the
you can quickly see the many different
feedbacks and interactions going on and
many of these things are things that are
going to be talked about today so with
all of these different factors going on
there's a lot of uncertainty a lot of
things were thinking about science is
complex with uncertainty in many
different levels and many different
feedbacks as well so we see positive
feedbacks like snow ice albedo which
could exacerbate things and we can see
cases like clouds with both they hit
list is both positive and negative
feedbacks so I'm not going to go through
yes one of these lights that's a great
idea that one thanks much better so now
that you can see my slide this is again
from the IPCC ar5 working group ones
figure 12 and really what we're looking
at here are two things one is this is
emphasizing the different feedbacks that
occurring and these are feedbacks that
exacerbate uncertainty to the extent
that we know them it's also emphasizing
the time scale and what's different
things are occurring and so the time
scales another thing that I think is
going to be useful for us to be talking
about today and I know marks going to
talk about that more next so with
everything from hours to days two years
two centuries with ocean circulation
down there at centuries which is a
really really important component here
but this is a conversation about
uncertainty and the IPCC does have its
own language about uncertainty it has
this virtual from virtually certain to
exceptionally unlikely very very very
fun virtually certain meaning 99 two
hundred percent very likely ninety to a
hundred percent likely sixty-six percent
so what we have here are these these
different words that are ascribed actual
meanings I'm not sure exactly where the
meanings come from in some cases
actually many cases but we have we have
language here that's going to help us
try and describe uncertainty it's not
actually quantifying and it's partly
quantifying uncertainty is a way to
think about it and the question is and
what I want I hope comes out of today is
what we really
to know for policy so fundamentally we
need to know what's the climate
sensitivity to greenhouse gas emissions
and what does it change in climate mean
for human welfare and these linked
questions are why we're bringing this
audience together this group of people
together we really want to understand
how uncertainty at the lower level
downstream translates into uncertainty
upstream how does in certainty in
climate sensitivity in greenhouse gas
emissions there are many different
feedbacks going on many things going on
how does that translate into this change
in climate into human welfare and so
that's where the economic models and
integrate assessment models come in i'm
going to give an overview of what how
the IPCC sets up their standard approach
I'm sure people here are going to add a
lot more detail to that so I will be
quick here the equilibrium climate
sensitivity is something that we're
going to probably talk a lot about in
the integrate assessment models it's
often called the temperature sensitivity
coefficient it's a key coefficient in
these economic models how much the
global mean they're near surface air
temperature changes with the sustained
doubling of co2 now it's obviously a
simplification everyone recognizes that
there's no regional variation in this
one number the time scale is vague there
are many greenhouse gases so there's
clearly a simplification but it's you
know been very useful in the modern
climate science scientists work with it
very very often and it's then translated
into the integrated assessment modeling
community and in contrast is also the
transient climate response which is
capturing the path to get to the
equilibrium in the modern climate models
it captures the annual mean surface
temperature following a steady increase
in forcing over 50 to 100 year time
period so we have we can have
uncertainty and under both of these and
of course we're missing other details as
well by focusing on these two so we have
Anthony Milner here and these are some
PDFs compiled by Anthony millionnaire
just to give us a sense about this broad
set of distributions so these are
probability density functions giving us
the distribution of the
equilibrium climate sensitivity
parameter so the temperature sensitivity
parameter and the economic models and
you see here this this ranges up to ten
many of them are fat-tailed so there's
some probability of extreme events of
thresholds of feedbacks leading to much
larger changes and we see much more
quickly dropping off at the beginning
now here we have and this is that's a
little tough to read which is not
entirely my fault but we see chris
forest is in there we see many of the
people who are here are actually have
contributed to this so this is one way
of quantifying the uncertainty we're
here we're attempting to actually put
down pin down numbers on the
distribution of what we expect could
happen with a doubling of co2 how about
the IPCC the ar5 so here the equilibrium
climate sensitivity distributions are
not done there don't actually have full
distributions but they do give us a
sense that the distribution so what we
see here is many different methods being
used to compute the climate sensitivity
everything from paleoclimate to
climatological constraints and
instruments and then a combination at
the bottom it's not entirely clear where
that combination comes from I'm hoping
someone here can can help me understand
where that combination comes from but
what we do see is is that that gray area
and the gray shaded range marks the
likely so likely with 66 to 100% the
likely 1.5 to 4.5 degree range so that's
the likely 1.5 to 4.5 degree range
sixty-six percent and so one thing that
you could do so say you are an
integrated assessment modeler who has a
temperature sensitivity coefficient in
your model you could imagine taking that
and and fitting some sort of
distribution what about a normal
distribution that's not going to be
fat-tailed you could imagine fitting
some distribution over that and that's
probably the the very first thing that
that you know an economist like myself
who's working an integrator and a great
assessment model would think to do now I
see that there are probably issues with
that and that's these are some of the
choose that I hope would talk about
today also the transient climate
response I loved it in the IPCC they
actually do have some distributions for
the transient climate response so should
I should mention that this is the draft
version so it is subject to change but
this is the draft version that is posted
on the web not the Foley published
version but should integrate assessment
models i AMS include a transient
response roughly in line with the
central estimate here how does this play
it should this play into the models as
well is a really good question and at
the moment in most cases it doesn't but
perhaps it does in some cases and we'll
hear about that as well particularly
during the day we hear about to the
extent that which these types of
responses play a role in the models as
well so let me lay out the goals for the
day the way I see the goals of the day
and maybe you all are coming in with
different expectations but my goals for
the day so I want to start and
reinvigorate this conversation has begun
I will grant that other people have
talked about this before a timely
conversation I mentioned all the things
going on right now between climate
scientists and economists about climate
sensitivity and about uncertainty in
climate sensitivity we really want to do
better at trying to quantify this
uncertainty and understand it better
what is the latest in climate scientists
in climate science that economist should
know this is an important factor the
especially economic modelers who are
working with the integrated assessment
models what do economists need is inputs
from climate scientists to better
parameterize their model this is
something that I hope the discussion
will cover as well and that it could be
useful for climate scientists to know so
that they can better understand how
their own work is being used as an input
into the policy process then what what
is the best evidence suggests for the
distribution of climate sensitivity to
use in economic modeling study so i will
say that i have another motivation for
this workshop bill mordhaus and i are
working under a deal we funded grant to
try and understand how uncertainty in
primitives such as the climate
sensitivity lead to uncertainty and
outputs of climate models so in
emissions paths uncertainty in welfare
and damage estimates so we're actually
doing looking at climate sensitivity
we're looking at
elation we're looking at GDP we're
looking at some very primitive some
primary factors we're trying to find the
very best the very very best
distributions of uncertainty over those
three different parameters and we're
mapping them through a whole slew of
models so we have six or seven models in
there right now hopefully maybe we'll
get one or two more and these models are
integrated assessment models that use
these primitive parameters including
climate sensitivity as an input and then
at the end you could imagine they they
have a whole bunch of economic
calculations in there and they spit out
at the end emissions and welfare and a
variety of other factors that can then
be used to understand better the
economic implications for different
policies to address climate change so we
have this project underway and well and
so I have added motivation to really
want to understand what's going on here
because we're looking for that
sensitivity distribution we want to
understand what is that distribution
look like how should we be modeling that
in these models and what's the best what
is the latest state of the climate
science so from my own personal view I'd
be very interested to hear what people
think we should do should we be using
the IPCC should we be modifying it
somehow what would you be using but
beyond that it's also valuable
bellwether about our state of the
knowledge and I think we have some great
people here who can help us understand
what the state of the knowledge is let
me give some ideal outcomes for today
first of all I'm a broader picture a
better understanding of what the latest
climate science says about climate
sensitivity so if not the IPCC ar5
distributions you know what
distributions if not the ecs TCR
processes so if you're not don't want to
talk about equilibrium climate sensitive
and you want to talk about our system
sensitivity or another way of looking at
sensitivity how should we be modeling
those how should those feed into models
and that will be talked about today as
well so I'm not going to go into that
but I also hope that there's an exchange
here that helps clients climate
scientists understand how their work is
being used in the integrated assessment
modeling community then the third one I
have a question mark that's
why possible that we could have some
written output come out of this there's
a possibility of bring some of us
together on either an academic article
or even just an op-ed that lays out some
of the insights gleaned today I hope
that there will be some insights gleaned
today I imagine there will be many and
can possibly bring together some of
these insights and either as an op-ed to
the popular press and or as an academic
article that brings together some of the
ideas that have been brought out that
haven't yet been put forth in a way
that's a constructive way that others
might find interesting as well